speaking of scams yeah
phase going public phase is going public
i couldn't really believe this honestly
i [ __ ] meant to read the website they
had a they have a whole thing about it's
another snpac deal but it's a spec which
means that they don't have to provide
they don't have to make an s1 i think
they don't have to provide their
financial data no because they're
technically merging with this company
that's already going public apparently
it values them at around a billion
dollars which i kind of find i don't
know i i don't know i
i kind of find that hard to believe
honestly
that means they're probably making
a hundred million dollars a year in
revenue yeah i'm just thinking of what
else is worth a billion like kim
kardashian's worth a billion and she
sells a [ __ ] ton of stuff every day do
you think more people like facebook what
did i just say i meant 100 million bucks
a year yeah right yeah yeah so like
around 10 million bucks 10 million bucks
a month in
revenue give or take do you think more
people like faze than kim k
no
right so i was like if kim k's were the
bill and faze kind of like
is a blip on her radar could you really
reasonably say that they're worth a
billion
i don't know i mean it's just a brand
thing then it's like brand recognition
and i just want to see their numbers i
want to know how much what do they do
how do they make money how do they make
money do they take a cut of every phase
members streaming revenue
but even then you'd need a [ __ ] ton of
people to generate that much revenue
especially with the staff that they have
i think they're kind of like full screen
where they lock up those big brand deals
where it's like they get like big
marketing budget from like pepsi they
get like a quarter million dollars and
maybe they just do that with like 10 or
15 brands and then yeah they do merch
and then some other stuff but i mean
that's that's the interesting part is
when they go public we'll get to see
that yeah can you imagine if
the whole like
like what if like the foundation of them
making money is something really
embarrassing yeah it's like it's like
it's like and our biggest earning our
biggest earner this year
was minecraft timmy
minecraft timmy pulled in 750 million
dollars and all the kids with tattoos
brought in about a hundred grand
all i know is i'm gonna buy stock so
that i can get myself phase shareholder
yeah
come on you dab them up in public hey
what's up face shareholder what's your
name again
milk me man
faze milk me i i don't like so trump's
back right
i mean it was like a 20 billion dollar
market cap on friday or something like
that right they didn't have a single
product i mean they do they have truth
social or whatever but it's it's a fork
of like another
social media app i'm pretty sure yeah i
think it's decentralized technically i
don't know i was listening to something
else on it but apparently they didn't
really write any of their own code it's
like open source and they just forked it
they just cloned it from another project
so they don't have like any anything
right any ip nothing the entire market
cap was all basically based on hype and
the fact that it's trump's brand and
he'll do something with it right so they
raise enough money where they can
basically acquire anyone so i'm
wondering if this is the same thing
which makes you think it's just
capitalizing on all the kids that are
faze fans that have robin hood that are
gonna buy stock in this company they're
gonna raise like 200 million bucks and
then they can they can do they can make
real moves with that but for right now
faze to me doesn't scream like media
conglomerate or organization that i
would invest in i don't think well and
you just made me think that it'd be
really funny if trump raised enough
money
he just like walks right up to twitter
he's like guess what i have enough
and i'm taking it back
he just buys twitter and picks everyone
up
i am going to be the only user
we're going to call it trump
this is it i've just posted a new trump
today
make sure to re-trump me oh wait no you
can't i'm the only guy on here
just takes that [ __ ] back
and he's personally banning everyone
he sends out a trump and then everyone's
like get the [ __ ] up blocked deleted
just [ __ ] taking them out one by one
i mean why truth
that's where you're gonna [ __ ] call
your social media app why not
truth re-truth that's what it calls
that's what it's called when you retweet
someone re-truth yeah [ __ ] it i mean
you've raised billions of dollars you
can't hire like one branding firm to
make up a word for you like every social
every other social media app i'm excited
for call it like biz did or something
like that you know nah see boring biz
did that's kind of cool
make sure you re-bonnify me like that's
better than truth no dude truth is what
like that's like his whole ethos right
like i'm telling the truth this fake ass
media like this and that do you know
that is such call it like truths with a
z or something like something cool no
dude it's so bold to just have an app in
the app store that just says truth on it
that is crazy there probably are like 50
already yeah fair i'm just excited for
him to take that word away from the
what's the anti-smoking
program um
yeah that's truth isn't it yeah i'm i'm
excited to see him take that orange yeah
yeah because i i hate their commercials
yeah so i'm just really excited to see
how they work that out yeah the truth
about smoking and also the truth about
truth is we're not associated with
but you guys are orange wait now hold on
yeah see this is gonna be so funny
depression stick what so they call it's
gonna be funny when trump takes his
website away from them does it actually
cause depression
i don't know dude are you sad how about
cody and well do depression hi guys
we're smoking vape
for two weeks straight we're gonna see
if we feel
horrible at the end of it
we're just hopelessly addicted to jewel
at the end so after two weeks of vape
we've decided to move on to oxycontin
[Music]
by the way
i have to call out i completely
butchered the gravity of what purdue
pharma did
they [ __ ]
[Music]
got
oxycontin re-labeled by the fed to say
it's non-addictive
really and that's the big issue is that
they got a custom label from the fed
that enabled them to
um
sell anywhere like any [ __ ] pharmacy
and it could be distributed for
literally anything because it was
non-addictive oh wow and it contradicted
everything that doctors knew about like
opioids and stuff they're like no dude
that is severely addictive like it's not
and that's why i was more [ __ ] up when
the whole 12-hour thing wasn't working
they're like ah just double the dosage
because they were pumping them with like
800x morphine jesus christ they made 35
billion dollars in the first year or
something or maybe that was the end they
made 30 yeah is the end they made 35
billion off oxycontin and they on record
killed
235 000 people oh my god and that's just
like disgusting yeah that's just
recorded death that's not even like
i tried it and now i've moved on to
heroin like insane by the way
if you do know anything else about faze
going public
i want to know in the comments because
i'm actually really really curious
i mean it it could be in a [ __ ]
incredible move right yeah yeah
it's just like i just to me those guys
like don't work you know what i'm saying
if all of a sudden they're all gonna be
worth like a hundred million bucks
it's gonna piss me right off
even if they i mean who cares
i don't i just you know i know it's me i
care
it's okay to care you could say you're
envious yeah i mean that's why we've
talked [ __ ] about jake for so long yeah
i mean he's you know he's rich he's he's
living it up he's apparently logan
versus mike tyson might happen oh who
gives a [ __ ] i'm just jealous